Інавгурація Володимира Путіна ось уже вчетверте
відбулася саме 7 травня. І дата – не єдине спільне
у заходів, які пройшли у Великому Кремлівському палаці
в 2000-му, 2004, 2012 та 2018 роках.
За 18 років правління Путіна виробився своєрідний ритуал,
головна мета якого – демонстрація спадкоємності влади,
вважають експерти у Німеччині.
Це в певному сенсі свято царя. Це інсценування
влади в Росії, президент як головна фігура
в російській політиці. Це дуже символічний захід,
на якому Путін виступає як сильна фігура.
Це урочисте святкування влади,
це цілком відповідає прагненням Москви виступати у якості
глобального гравця та впливати на світову політику.
Російський істеблішмент намагається всидіти на двох стільцях.
Тобто одночасно стати спадкоємцем як "червоного проекту",
тобто Радянського Союзу, так і "Білого проекту" –
Російської імперії. І саме ланцюжок спадкоємності
демонструється у всьому: починаючи від помпезності,
золота, Георгієвської зали Кремля, і завершуючи
відповідним вбранням людей, які супроводжують
президента в момент складання присяги.
Німецькі експерти підкреслюють, що в Німеччині
інавгурація як канцлера, так і президента
відбувається значно скромніше, ніж у Росії.
І Меркель, і Штайнмаєр складали присягу в Бундестазі.
Лише потім у президента був військовий парад біля палацу Бельвю.
Однак спочатку – присяга в Бундестазі.
Цим підкреслюється відданість демократії, служіння народу.
У Німеччині функціонує демократія, в якій немає короля чи кайзера.
Це парламентська демократія, в якій президент
не відіграє важливу роль. Такий формат, як в Росії,
суперечить традиціям і політичній культурі Німеччини
та інших європейських країн.
Російський формат вступу глави держави на посаду –
це вияв авторитарного стилю правління,
відзначають німецькі експерти.